the data are in the science is settled
america is getting super duper gay
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from matt
who says that for breakfast joe biden
loves muffins
because muffins spelled backwards is
sniff em
got em that is true joe biden
does love smelling people's hair and
when you want to shave your facial hair
you should check out harry's razors
harry's delivers a close comfortable
shave at a fair price
only two dollars per refill how do they
do it
harry's team combined a simple ergonomic
design with five
sharp blades they source their steel
from sweden and manufacture their blades
in
their world-class blade factory harry's
german factory
is one of the select few manufacturers
in the world that have mastered the
technology to create a
gothic arch the gold standard for razor
blade
grinding they stand behind the quality
of their blades so much that they have a
hundred percent
money back guarantee on harrys.com i
really love this razor
it is simple i'm not saying it's
minimalist it's just very simple it's
very intuitive
and it's just high quality it's just
about
the blade gives me best shave i've ever
had for a limited time
harry's has an exclusive offer for
listeners of my show
new customers can get a hairy starter
set with
free body wash for just three dollars at
harry's dot com slash knowles
that's over a 16 value for just three
dollars you'll get a five blade razor
weighted handle foaming shave gel a
travel cover which i really love
and a travel sized body wash it's a
terrific deal but act fast while
supplies last go to harris.com
knowles to redeem your offer go check
out harry's
razors there is a gallup poll out
that shows you know what great respect i
have for science and data
gallup poll comes out and shows that
america is getting
extremely gay specifically that's
not specific enough america is
identifying
much more as l g
b t and you know this is a little
complicated because
the l and the g s presuppose that there
are biological sexes
and you know men are men and women are
women and gay guys or men who are
attracted to men and lesbians or women
who are attracted to women but then the
t
comes in and confounds all of that
because the t presupposes that there's
not really any such thing as men or
women and women can become men and
men can become women and you're not
really born this way you know everything
is kind of fluid and changing
all the time so it's very very confused
but the number of
americans who identify with any of those
letters increasing pretty dramatically
the traditional percentage of americans
who identify this way
it's about two percent maybe maybe
goes up to three percent by 2017 that
number rose
to four and a half percent so it rose
pretty significantly and then in just
the last four years
that number's risen again very
significantly to 5.6
so it's getting quicker and quicker but
the the more curious number is when you
drill down
into the generations because for
americans born before
1965 the number of lgbt identifying
americans
is around two percent a little bit less
than two percent
when you get to millennials that number
jumps
to about nine point one percent
that is uh pretty pretty high then
when you get to gen z
uh that number jumps extremely high that
jumps to 15.9 percent
of americans i
have to believe that there is some
biological basis
for sexual desire you know there's this
kind of debate
are you born this way or does culture do
it you know i don't think that you just
sort of freely choose your sexual
desires
so i i don't think for instance that
liberace
was ever going to end up married to a
woman i just that just does not seem
very likely to me however
i don't think that 16 of zoomers
just so happen to be born this way right
with all these sort of
ever expanding uh alphabet identities i
don't
if the numbers were increasing that
dramatically
i i would have to assume there's
something in the water
if the numbers were if it was purely a
biological thing
100 percent and the numbers were
increasing that way alex jones would
have to be right right there they're
turning the frickin
zoomers gay right that would i guess
more
t or g or b or you know it
kind of gets very complicated which is
kind of my point i think human sexuality
is just a very complicated thing
and there are all these different
factors in here but surely
surely politics and culture
plays some role in this as well
you know i did a book club episode not
that long ago
with spencer clavin and we were
discussing plato's symposium and plato's
symposium is very strange
for modern readers to read because it's
basically a big gay dinner party
and so a lot of modern sort of
conservatives or christians will read
this and say wait a second
what's going on here and there's a huge
cultural factor at play in these sorts
of
behaviors the reason this poll
i think matters is because right now if
cultural and political factors
have some role here the cultural and
political factors are
all pushing in one direction namely
away from a sort of traditional
understanding of these sexual questions
toward a much more radical one for
instance we talked about my friend ryan
t
anderson and his extremely hilariously
titled book when harry became sally
now that's kicked off of amazon amazon
used to remove products that were
politically incorrect but they had
this exception for books they were not
going to remove
books so you can buy books by hitler on
amazon right you know you can
you can buy any sort of book that you
find distasteful
and you can buy books that express
mainstream conservative opinions like
men cannot become women
they sort of under the radar got rid of
this exception the other day
so now all of a sudden ryan anderson's
book which is very academic work on the
rise of transgenderism is an ideology
that book is gone now you're not allowed
to say that
amazon private company right so this is
in the field of culture but they've got
a lot of political power too
they are now limiting the
scope of of a reasonable and acceptable
thought
on these sexual questions and
specifically on the
the gender question because i think most
of the way the
culture and politics are pushing in
recent years is pushing in the direction
of the t
in the direction of gender ideology
this is now being considered hate speech
can you imagine what this means for
other sorts of conservative books that
in any way touch on these sorts of
questions
my book coming up speechless this book
is going to be out in june speechless
controlling words controlling minds
no doubt it's going to fall afoul of the
amazon policy if ryan anderson's book is
going to fall valve it
certainly minus two and probably many
others as well beyond just that kind of
cultural business realm
the government is pushing in this
direction there is a
a bill before the california state
assembly
one of the most insane legislative
bodies in the country
that is going to require department
store chains
to make their children's section gender
neutral
they want this to be in effect by 2023
this is called california bill 2826
from assemblyman evan lowe you'll be
shocked to find out that this person is
a democrat
this would apply to stores with 500 or
more employees so if you go into target
or something right you say oh i want to
buy a little uh little outfit for
johnny you what do you do you go in you
go to the children's section then you go
to the boys section
what this bill would say is no you're
you're not allowed to have a boys
sections it's basically just going to
make it a lot more time-consuming to
pick out outfits and toys for your
children
because they're not you're not going to
be allowed to label anything why because
the premise here is there's really no
such thing as little boys and little
girls
little boys and little girls are not
different underscores
why the gender ideology is so at odds
with kind of traditional
homosexual activism because
the homosexual premise premises there's
actually there's a huge difference
between boys and girls and and don't
make a boy who's attracted to a boy
go date a girl the gender stuff gets rid
of all of that but this is being pushed
at the
governmental level then
in this kind of middle ground at a
school in minnesota
so it's not quite the government but it
sort of is the government it's public
and it's
education is coercive there's a middle
school teacher
who is teaching children who are 11 to
13 years old
who is who is basing at least one of his
lesson plans
around praising a transvestite
prostitute
take a lo now that we have zoom school
now that people aren't really going to
classrooms
you can watch some of these lessons take
a listen to mr peruko's
person of the day so i apologize for the
very long wait for our suggester
but farrukkan's haruko harukin veruco's
person of the day
is marcia p johnson
so if you don't know much about marshall
p johnson they were known as a fierce
advocate for gay rights
and aids as an aids activist and a
self-identified drag queen
in addition to all of their advocacy
marcia was also well known
for their president for their presence
at the stonewall uprising
and the subsequent demonstrations
throughout greenwich village
that protested the police raids that had
been taking place at local gay gathering
places
johnson's work paved the way for a
louder and more prominent voice in the
injustices that were being done
in and to the gay community the
interesting part here is that
johnson himself was actually
discriminated against by the community
uh for being a drag queen in 1973 the
committee in charge of a pride parade
said that they were not going to allow
dre queens at the march
because they felt that they were giving
the community a bad name
that's actually a very telling aspect i
mean first of all this lesson plan is
obviously not
suitable for 11 year olds you should not
be
paying tax money and sending your kids
to schools so that your 11 year old
can hear hey geographies of transvestite
prostitutes that's
crazy but what he says there at the end
is he says you know actually uh
the gay community in the 70s didn't
really like this guy because
they thought it was it was like kind of
just too weird it was too out there
for the kind of activism they were doing
and you see the same
this same kind of issue today i mean
all of us have gay friends no gay people
and uh i have yet to encounter one of
them who say yeah this this whole
transgender movement where you're
forcing kids to learn this crazy
ideology and question their sex and
sometimes go on puberty blockers
that's great oh yeah man i love that
that's terrific
no of course and that there was that
tension going back to the 70s but right
now
the left the mainstream left schools
corporations
the government is pushing
this kind of ideology on children and it
actually goes up
all the way to the federal level even
moderate joe biden in this return
to normalcy sort of administration is
appointing people to very high level
positions
in the department of health and human
services who
do not just embrace this gender ideology
themselves do not just uh you know
take this premise and by the way when
you're in a position of power
and you're embracing these kinds of
premises it
is inevitable at least in this day and
age that you're going to force those
premises
onto your work and on to society
but there are people in in the
administration who are supporting
this ideology for children puberty
blockers
for children not doesn't seem very
safe to me one great way to keep your
house safe check out
ring ring makes me feel
safe and it makes everyone else who has
it feel safe
too i love ring because i'm getting a
lot of packages at my house
food stuff for the little baby
in-laws sometimes carrying packages and
it just depends you know who do you want
to open it for well you can see and
speak to whoever is at your door whether
you are in the back of the house
maybe you're at your office maybe you
are on the other
side of the world it's just a very
simple way to feel safe
ring also has a ton of terrific other
products that you can install it's very
simple
it's very affordable if you want ring
alarm this whole home security system
for yourself i just love that especially
when i'm traveling
sweet little alisa and cute little june
can know
who is outside the door before they open
the door
it's also a great housewarming gift
especially because it's not that
expensive
right now get a special offer on the
ring welcome kit at ring.com
knowles comes with rings video doorbell
3 and chime pro
the perfect way to upgrade your front
door and start your ring experience go
to ring.com
knowles that is ring.com knowles
a very prominent appointee at
the department of health and human
services for joe biden
is a fellow by the name of dr rachel
levine
dr rachel levine is named rachel because
he
identifies as a woman a man
who believes himself to be a woman is
in a leadership role at the department
of health and human services
just going to leave that there that's
actually
i don't want to speak that broadly today
i want to get into a very specific
aspect of what assistant secretary
of hhs rachel levine believes
rachel levine does not just want to
force
gender ideology on our sort of national
self-understanding
rachel levine also supports puberty
blockers
for children fundamentally screwing with
children's biochemistry because
johnny decides to pick up a barbie doll
or jane decides to play with a toy truck
in january of 2020 so not that long ago
rachel levine tweeted out quote a new
study has found that transgender youth
with access to a puberty blocker have a
decline in chances of suicide
plus mental health problems now and in
the future by the way
these studies are few and far between
and their methodologies are very
questionable
so one ought to be cautious with these
sorts of new
studies that just conveniently happen to
back up people's deeply held political
views
this study is important because it's the
first to show the specific association
there you have it it's the first
obviously you've got to look into this
more deeply but
the argument here is people who suffer
from gender
confusion and sexual confusion are
depressed and anxious
and in the case of transgenderism can be
suicidal
and therefore
what we need to do as a society is
embrace ideas
even if those ideas are manifestly false
like the idea that men can become
women in order to reduce this rate of
suicidality
and we even it's what's so important is
we need to push this on
kids we talked yesterday about how the
reason that the left focuses on
education is because education
shapes the way we view the world and
when we're young
we are much more susceptible to things
that's why we have a rating system for
movies and tv shows
it's because if an adult is exposed to
certain material
it's going to be much less influential
on their thought one way or the other
than if a little kid is exposed to
certain material that's why we have
rules around
we used to have rules around pornography
for children that are different than for
adults if
if you wanted to go buy a playboy down
the street you'd have to show an id
right kids don't get to do that but
adults because you're a little more
formed
the idea is theoretically you can handle
it this is the argument
behind age of consent laws the reason
that it's creepy when an old guy dates a
young teenager
is because the young teenager or younger
they're not
really free to consent because the the
idea here is that through education
specifically through liberal education
right education to make sense of your
liberty
you tame your base passions you tame
your appetites
you develop your higher faculties you
develop your will
and then you can exercise your freedom
right now the left in pursuit of gender
ideology and really they're just using
gender ideology as a way to get more
power
is throwing age of consent laws out the
window
if it suits their ideology they're
willing to pump kids full of a bunch of
chemicals and stop them from going
through puberty
what happened to age of consent it's a
really bizarre ironic
phenomenon too because we we talked
about the marilyn manson sex scandal a
few weeks ago
how this actress evan rachel wood is
accusing marilyn manson of abuse
and what's interesting about the story
is that evan rachel wood
consented to this relationship i think
she was engaged to marilyn manson for a
long time
she consented to all the weird depraved
sexual acts that he was performing on
her
i think maybe with some exception but it
seems as though consent was a big part
of this
and yet what she says is i couldn't
really give consent
even though i know i i consented you
know we were in this relationship but i
wasn't really giving consent because
he groomed me when i was 18 years old
and he was older
he manipulated me he brainwashed me i
wasn't really in in control of my
liberty i couldn't
really make a free choice so at the same
time
that the left is questioning the ability
of certain adults to give consent
they are now embracing the ability of
three-year-olds to give consent
or ten-year-olds to give consent to to
stop going through puberty
make life-altering decisions that
doesn't make
any sense except in the raw pursuit of
power
what's funny is the kind of evan rachel
wood and marilyn manson of it all gets
back to a much
more conservative understanding of
liberty which is that liberty isn't the
freedom
to do whatever you want pursue whatever
desire you have
that true liberty is the right
to do what you ought to do that's what
lord acton thought it's our founding
father's thought
it's what old uncle aristotle thought
it's what christ teaches in the gospels
but somehow we've just completely lost
our minds on this sort of thing
so you've got the culture pushing in one
direction
and the reason that the left focus is on
sex
is because sex is very important the
left often accuses the right
of being obsessed with sex and the and
more broadly speaking the culture wars
but you'll notice in all of these sort
of
sexual specifically but cultural more
broadly debates
it's never the right that is aggressing
right it's nev it's always the left
that's pushing this crazy stuff
so what what the left does is they go in
and they say hey
we're gonna pump your kids full of
puberty blockers because we think that
boys can become girls
and then conservatives will say whoa man
that's weird no no don't do that and
they'll say why are you so obsessed with
sex stop
come on just stop obsessing about that
it's not it's it's
totally normal don't don't be weird
we're just gonna go pump your kids full
of puberty blockers don't
but don't be so obsessive and weird
about that we say ah i think you're the
one
that's pushing a cultural agenda and you
see this clearly
in the statistics here i'm sort of half
joking when i say america is getting
super duper gay
what i actually suspect is that maybe
for some people who
some people probably you know they they
know their sexual desires from
pretty young age and these things are
have maybe
more of a biological basis for some
people it's more of a margin call
and you know maybe they're confused and
they have lots of different desires
human sexuality is complicated
and then for some people i suspect
they're just identifying this way
because there is social cachet to it in
the same way
that our culture now uh discourages
people from being white right you have
hr trainings in corporate america
that say be less white so what do you
get you get white people pretending to
be black
you get people like rachel dolezal you
get people
like that nyu professor you get people
all sorts of people
who are pretending to be different races
it seems like these stories crop up
every couple of months
in the same way i suspect you're getting
people who have basically
ordinary sexual desires who are now
saying no i'm other
i'm trans i'm gender non-conforming i'm
a
uh homosexual that's a new one that's
where you don't
put i think it stands for postmodern and
it means you just don't want people to
know your sexual views
so it means like you're a straight guy
but you you want to sound like really
cool
there's one i read called neutra this is
in the list of the hundred genders
i believe is when you are sexually
confused but also french
so you just become a
you get people who are identifying that
way because it carries
social currency and the way that being
able to claim
membership in any aggrieved minority
confers social currency today
so too it can be true in the realm of
race
that can be true in the realm of sex and
that's obviously true in the realm
of sexual desire as well so as you've
got the culture all pushing in this
direction
this does have real world
consequences it has real world
consequences
in for instance the discouragement of
the forming of
families and when i say family i don't
mean the sense that
you know we can all have different kinds
of families that's i mean i mean
specifically families that
will have children that is declining a
lot
uh i think some sort of squishy
conservatives were celebrating a story
that came out a while ago
that divorce rates are hitting all-time
lows well that's great but you got to
read
read the second part of the story which
is that marriage rates are hitting
all-time lows too
and what happens when people don't get
married birth rates
are hitting lower and lower numbers the
united states right now
is a dying country in the sense that we
are not
replacing ourselves our birth rate is
below
replacement is it possible
that cultural and political factors have
a
role in this as well is it possible that
on the cultural front
this idea that you are discouraged from
forming a family discouraged from
forming sort of
the traditional nuclear model
does that play a role in it does the
economic front play a role in it
the idea that you're encouraged to just
delay having kids delay getting married
pursue your career work work work
everyone in the household needs to go
work
kind of the i guess i'm sounding a
little left wing here because this is in
a way a critique
of modern capitalism but i i suspect
that too
is discouraging families and
specifically discouraging people from
having babies
and now you've got some republicans some
very conservative populist republicans
and even some squishes like mitt romney
pushing back and saying wait a second if
our public policy is ordered toward
not having kids and not having families
maybe we should just rework our public
policy
to encourage those sorts of things one
great way
to preserve memories of of your kids
when they were little of your parents of
your grandparents
paint your life paintyourlife.com will
get you a world-class painting i choose
oil but you have other options too
from a photograph or multiple
photographs of a loved one of a special
place
of you know if the kids when they're
little of your grandparents of wherever
i have used this service multiple times
i had a portrait made of my mother and
it's i haven't hung any of my paintings
yet in my house so i've just got it kind
of they're all like lining the floor in
my living room
whenever people enter my living room
they
go right to the portrait of my mother
they say oh my gosh it's such a
beautiful portrait it says paint
yourlife.com it's unbelievable you
wouldn't
believe the artistic quality until you
see it at painterlife.com there is no
risk if you do not love the final
painting your money will be
refunded but you are going to love the
final painting guaranteed right now as a
limited time offer
get 20 off your painting that is twenty
percent off
plus free shipping to get this special
offer text the word michael to sixty
four thousand
that is mich ael to sixty four thousand
text michael to sixty four thousand
paint your life celebrate the moments
that matter most
term supply available at painterlife.com
terms text michael
to what number 64 000. also uh
definitely check out the ben shapiro
show today where ben will be
dissecting the cancel culture war and
the wars over canceling and over
canceling cancel culture and over
canceling
the people who want to cancel cancel
culture also there's a ton of
narratives going on right now very
difficult to keep track of all of the
latest controversies and non-traverses
that the left decides to be offended by
so get ready for the daily wire's newest
show soon to be released
debunked where ben exposes leftist
fallacies
in 15 minutes or less this show will be
available exclusively to daily wire
members
so if you're not already a member go to
dailywire.com subscribe
and use code debunked to get 25 off you
do not want to miss
then use code debunked for 25 off today
head over to dailywire.com we'll be
right back with a lot more
the collapse of families
is a social problem
and a political problem and an economic
problem
it is the family is the
bedrock political institution
if that collapses as it has collapsed
look at marriage rates
look at birth rates that poses
an existential truly an existential
threat to the country
a lot of our other hot controversial
political issues
come from that because when you have a
country that's below replacement when
you have a dying country
people who want to keep the economy
going are going to encourage
mass migration which is what you're
seeing people are going to
obviously mass migration involves lots
of questions of assimilation what the
character of the country is
who americans are what does it mean if
the sort of native born americans
don't want to have kids then other
people are going to come in how do you
assimilate those people
lots and lots of questions mitt romney
can't believe i've got to say a nice
thing about mitt romney
but i do you know i try to play fair i
i've said many
tough things about mitt romney for at
least a decade now
but he is seeing a problem romney and
tom cotton are proposing
a minimum wage plan this follows after
mitt romney proposed a plan of direct
payments to families who have children
now i don't know that i love romney's
proposal on the direct payments to
families but i like the idea of it i
like the idea that our public policy is
not just
neutral or public policy for a long time
has been discouraging
family formation has been discouraging
people from having kids
and so now we shouldn't just throw our
hands up in the air
we should try to fix that policy we
should try to govern use the political
power that people give us
to try to turn that back a little bit
more in the other direction
so romney has that plan and he's also
pushing this idea
of a 10 minimum wage now generally
speaking
at least the more libertarian-minded
people among the conservative movement
hate the idea of minimum wage and
minimum wage is a dangerous thing
because there are a lot of
problems that can result from that but i
actually think this proposal from romney
and cotton is a pretty good one
which is that
right now the left is pushing for a 15
minimum wage it's
almost certainly going to happen so how
can conservatives
mitigate this and also make it work for
us well
15 maybe it's a little high maybe that's
too radical a way
to increase the minimum wage so what if
we did it a little more gradually a
little more conservatively you brought
it to 10
per hour you also had a carve out for
the youth minimum wage
so the youth minimum wage would increase
more more gradually for 25 an hour to
six dollars per hour
so you're not having young people
totally booted out of the labor market
uh in favor of p you know if everyone's
going to get 15 an hour you're going to
go for the person
who is more qualified who's older who
has more experience
this would also have some carve outs for
businesses with fewer than 20 employees
but then here's the key the legislation
would uh require e-verify
it would it would so you so democrats
are pushing this 15
minimum wage republicans are saying gosh
there's no way we're going to totally
avoid this but what if we
kind of make the minimum wage part of it
work a little more for us and then
use this minimum wage issue to get
e-verify and e-verify
is a way to discourage employers from
using
illegal foreign labor
that would be very good for families
that would be very good for american
workers
one of the reasons there are economic
pressures that have discouraged people
from family formation and from having
kids
namely you used to be able to support a
family on the wages of one american
worker
the other the other spouse would stay
home
now that's really very difficult and
part of that is because
a lot of especially lower wage workers
are competing with this
flood of of cheap foreign labor this is
something that conservatives have been
talking about a long time
but even old-school leftists like bernie
sanders have been talking about
who's been saying you know unlimited
immigration
is really good for zillionaires who want
to pay low wages
but it's really bad for the american
worker
the people pushing it it's this weird
kind of dynamic of
left-wingers in corporate america and
even the sort of libertarian
right-wingers like
the koch brothers for instance famously
vary in favor of much more
immigration so i think this is a
decent enough plan i like the big win of
e-verify
i can't i also can't believe i have to
say another nice thing about mitt romney
today
there's a lot of debate over the future
of the republican party and trump's role
in the republican party
you've got people like liz chaney who's
in-house leadership who
hates trump we'll get to her in a second
romney also obviously hates trump he was
a true never trumper he didn't vote for
trump either time
he doesn't like the guy at all but but
romney was asked about 2024
hey you know mitt do you have any
thoughts about 2024 do you think trump
will run
and romney calling it like he sees it he
says yeah
if trump does run he's going to win in a
landslide
will president trump continue to play a
role in my party i'm sure he will
he has by far the largest voice and a
big impact in my party
i don't know about his family members
whether they intend to do that
but but i expect he will continue
playing a role i don't know if he'll run
in 2024 or not but if he does
i yeah i'm pretty sure he will win the
nomination
uh you think he would win the nomination
oh i think he'd win the nomination if he
runs i mean a lot can happen between now
and 2024. so
uh and i'm not great at predicting i i'm
a i subscribe to yogi berra's philosophy
in that regard he said
i don't like i don't like predicting uh
particularly if the future's involved
so i i i don't really know what'll
happen there but i
i look at the polls and the polls show
that among the names being floated as
potential contenders in 2024
if you put president trump in there
among republicans he wins in a landslide
wins in a landslide so what mitt romney
is saying here and he actually
he goes on to say this pretty explicitly
what he's saying here is trump is the
leader of the republican party
because mitt then goes on later in the
interview and he says you know look i
represent a very small
portion of the republican party and
trump
represents the republican party that's
why he would win the nomination
in a landslide so romney
it's very actually a very good interview
because he also touches on
part of the trump phenomenon which is
this idea of populism
and few people would accuse mitt romney
of being a populist
except if you look at some of the
policies proposing
these days maybe there's an argument
that you could be made but mitt romney
makes a simple point it's it's a
a plain truth a self-evident truth that
populism is popular populism
uh is successful uh because it's popular
uh which is part of its name
uh and populism hasn't disappeared where
it tends to get installed whether
italy or argentina or peru and
uh and so there's a populist movement on
the right in our country and on the left
and those movements i don't believe are
going to be going away anytime
soon although i think over time
uh that policies that that endure and
that really helped the american family
will be more successful so i
remain if you will a more traditional
conservative than
than some of the populist uh rhetoric
within my party
uh mitt romney is such a tragic figure
mitt romney
it's too bad because he's saying a lot
of smart things in here and he's
actually doing a lot of smart things
right now but he just doesn't quite get
it he
i don't know i think for a lot of people
trump sort of broke them and i think he
doesn't
he actually doesn't understand what is
meant by populism
and his role in all of that
i i sort of think it's just because
romney's been running for president for
decades at this point he's just it's
kind of skewed his perception
you remember when when romney was
running for the senate against ted
kennedy
he said uh he basically ran away from
the legacy of reagan he ran away from
being called a conservative he said i
wasn't a conservative during the time of
reagan bush i was an independent during
the time of reagan bush
i'm i'm not that conservative i think he
ran it was sort of pro-abortion right
when he when he ran for senate
and then he pretends when he runs for
president he says i'm severely
conservative and now he says
i'm a traditional conservative well all
these terms are kind of
useless i want to i want to bring them
all down to earth
what romney is saying on his
by by intimating that we should have a
pro-family sort of
policy that's a populist idea
whatever populism you want to say is
motivating trump
i think a lot of it has to do with
overthrowing the old
ossified conservative political order of
the last 20 years
and saying hey wait a minute why are we
just serving these zillionaires who hate
our guts
why are we shilling for hedge fund
managers in wall street
the majority of whom don't like us at
all why are we supporting trade deals
that are bad for the american worker
why are we the kind of blue-collar base
of the republican party
doing these sorts of things that are
really killing us and breaking up our
families and breaking up
our society and breaking up our american
way of life let's not do that
let's break these old sort of silly
ideological
maxims that i don't think made very much
sense even when they were
more popular and let's focus on the
family
the worker the nation american
sovereignty getting out of this sort of
globalist
regime that is not really serving
most americans and certainly not
conserving our way of life romney's kind
of saying the same thing
saying yeah we need a very active policy
to support families
yeah we should maybe raise the minimum
wage but only in a way that will
curb immigration these are very populous
things
if any other politician were proposing
what romney is proposing right now
we would say oh yeah this is someone
part of the maga movement you know part
of the trump movement
but because it's romney and because
romney is often very distasteful
in the way he presents things uh we we
don't like it very much but
i i wish romney would embrace his inner
populist i think he actually would be
much more successful and some of the
wisest stuff he's done in his whole
career
all right i've said too many nice things
about generally squishy republicans so i
got to get back to knocking the squishes
this debate that that romney's talking
about
where he says you know yeah i like these
kind of populist ideas but i hate trump
i would never vote for him
the question is is what is trump's role
in the future of the republican party
and you saw it split almost perfectly
yesterday on c-span where you had the
republican
minority leader kevin mccarthy
answered a question about trump's role
in the party
in a pro-trump way and then liz cheney
this
lady who is sort of in leadership you
know it's a minor leadership role but
she is
she totally smacks trump down
do you believe president trump should be
speaking or former president trump
should be speaking at cpac this weekend
yes he should
congressman cheney that's up to cpac
i've been clear my views about
president trump and and the extent to
which following
accentuates fell on january 6th uh i
don't i don't believe that he should be
playing a role in the future of the
party or the country
on that high note
kevin mccarthy pretty funny here and
what's amazing is after
you can see the cringe start creeping on
him
as liz cheney answers she goes yeah i
hate trump he shouldn't have any role in
the party any role in the country
i'm liz cheney and i approve this
message mccarthy is just thinking ugh
and then once she finishes and he makes
a little joke they walk in
opposite directions mccarthy goes one
way cheney goes the other
my question listening to this is
why do republicans tolerate this woman
why on earth is liz cheney in leadership
well there's a practical reason she's an
elite or a technical reason rather
she's in leadership there was a vote on
her leadership she's in leadership
because
they made it a secret ballot if this had
been a public ballot she would not be in
leadership because everybody knows that
the republican base the republican
voters
do not think this woman represents them
because this woman doesn't represent
them
even mitt romney's willing to admit that
he says yeah i represent a small portion
of the republican party
and donald trump is the leader of the
republican party
is effectively what he's saying so i'm
not saying kick liz cheney out of the
house
though probably she should be primaried
and probably she would lose
i'm not saying kick mitt romney out of
the senate i'm actually kind of more on
mid-side here we're
saying yeah i represent the small
portion but trump's the leader okay if
he if trump is the guy who represents a
republican party
why on earth is liz
cheney in the leadership what is the
point of it
i'm saying yeah fine to disagree big
tent party i'm i'm cool with that i have
no i really have no problem with that
but in leadership this woman does not
represent the party
now shockingly i've got to get back to
some other
never-trumpers and kind of squishy
republicans saying some good things
never say on this show that i am unfair
or i'm only carrying water for certain
politicians
or others i uh i'm willing to compliment
the kind of never trumpers and the
squishes when they when they
do and say good things because i don't i
actually don't want to cast them into
outer darkness
all the time sometimes i do i actually
want to bring them over to our way of
thinking if if mitt romney
would just actually listen to the very
things that he is saying
and get over his deep-seated hatred of
donald trump who's a polarizing figure
we all grant
and if mitt romney could come on over
more to the conservative side of things
i think that would be great he's
obviously an intelligent guy
he's an articulate guy he's a good
looking guy right just as a
retail politics matter he looks good if
he could come over to our way of sinking
thinking great i welcome him in this is
true of a number of the other kind of
squishier republicans who've really gone
squishy in the age of trump guys like
ben sasse for instance who i thought
yesterday
had a terrific performance grilling
joe biden's nominee for the department
of health and human services
not the fellow who thinks he's a lady
the assistant secretary but the
actual uh nominee for secretary of hhs
the sarah ben sasse
who has invoked the ire of many
conservatives in recent
weeks and months because he's he was a
never-trumper and
he often attacks members of his own
party and he was censured by his own
state republican party sas had a great
performance yesterday
uh going after xavier becerra becerra
was the former attorney general
of california and a real real radical
becerra
went after nuns tried just like the
obama
biden administration did becerra went
after nuns because he wanted to force
them
to pay for abortion drugs
and contraceptives so sas grilled him on
this point
i try to say to senator grassley i
understand that
americans have different deeply held
beliefs
on this particular issue and and i
absolutely respect that
by the way i i have never sued the nuns
any nuns
i have taken on the federal government
uh but i've never sued any
uh affiliation of of nuns hold up
point that there before we really get
into what sas says
it is technically true that becerra
never sued nuns
what he did was even crazier
he wanted to sue nuns the federal
government under the trump
administration
would not let him sue nuns and to try to
force them to pay for abortion drugs and
contraceptives
so becerra sued the federal government
so that he could get his right back to
sue the nuns
and try to force them to pay for
abortion and contraceptives
sas totally not going to take his lame
excuses
you know well you're an incredibly smart
man you know well that what the federal
government did
was make sure that you couldn't target
the nuns so you sued the federal
government
because the federal government said the
nuns didn't have to buy contraceptive
insurance you can put 17 layers of
you were following the law to go after
the federal government for administering
the program or doing x or doing why that
made it difficult for you to
for california to administer the program
but it was just about nuns buying
contraceptive coverage
was there something else the federal
government did that you were suing them
for
when when in the case called california
versus little sisters of the poor
senator the case was not again that was
not the name of the case
and what i will tell you is that our
actions were based on
trying to follow the law that when the
federal government took action which we
believe did not
comport with the law at that point we
took action
and our action was based on the law and
so as i've said
we may disagree on how we see this and i
respect the differences that we may have
but my action was to follow the law no
it wasn't your your action was to
uh attack the law to
dispute the law in court because the
federal government
interpreted this federal law and
you didn't like it because the
government's interpretation said you
couldn't sue the nun so stop
please stop this ridiculous posturing
this ridiculous proceduralist posturing
and get to the heart of it
you wanted to sue the nuns to make them
pay for abortions and contraceptives
and the federal government didn't want
you to do it so you sued them
speaking of trying to grow the american
family speaking of
trying to reverse this course of
national death and decline
one good way to to reduce that is to
stop killing our
babies and to encourage a culture of
life rather than a culture of death
but because a good politician you know
he's a
he's a shrewd guy so he knows how to
portray this where if you didn't
know the facts of this case and you just
watched this exchange maybe you'd say oh
they both got good points in but sas
sas got to give it to him he won't let
up
what about the law as the federal
government's conscious
conscience exemptions applied in the
case where you sued the federal
government
what about the law applied to anybody
except the nuns and other similarly
situated religious institutions
you were targeting religious liberty
because what
what yeah what about the law i know
we're talking about the what about the
law though
what were you trying to do with the law
pal and this
this is the big issue right now under
moderate joe biden's administration
you've got the leader of hhs pushing
politics toward encouraging a culture of
contraception
and abortion this
is the issue you've got
this world in which the
the government right i think the
conservatives for too long have
kind of embraced this libertarian idea
that there's the government and the
government can never do anything and
anything the government does is bad and
you know we can't ever use political
power that people give us and uh
this has given the left the opportunity
to completely transform the culture
but politics and culture which is
a little blurry line in between those
things they can encourage things one way
or the other
and by the way when they say one thing
they exclude other things so getting
back to what we're talking to at the top
of the show
if you have a culture and a culture
backed up by a political regime
that says that it is simply a fact that
men can become women
women can become men and it's bigoted to
say otherwise and you
drill this into kids heads from
kindergarten onwards
and then you use the law to say we we
should
pump kids full of puberty blockers if
you know
jane likes to play football at
thanksgiving or something
and we should fundamentally change their
biochemistry what you're doing is you're
saying this is the way the world
works and all of those incentives are
going to be
compounded you know conservatives used
to understand how incentives work
you know when you incentivize something
you tend to get more of it when you
disincentivize something
you tend to get less of it for a long
time
the left was focused entirely on
transforming the culture
and the right was focused on getting
more tax cuts
and that was it and the the right
completely gave up
on these cultural sorts of issues and
the left aggressed and aggressed and
aggressed
on issues of race on issues of sex
we're seeing that all today the result
of this has been a politics of division
a politics of confusion
a politics of hollowing out our
institutions and our tradition
and we got some tax cuts look i like tax
cuts
i love tax cuts but there's much more
and if conservatives
whatever the conservative movement the
republican party is going to be in the
future
if it does not focus on preserving the
american
family then up from that the american
local polity you know local towns
thriving communities
and up from that the american sense of
nationhood the american sense of our way
of life if we don't preserve that
we are doing absolutely nothing
at all i'm michael nolsas the michael
knowles show more tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy bourie our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there